qu'ils s'appellent l'actrice la plus
populaire de france
alors michel ça vous surprendre avec
l'actrice la plus populaire de france où
vous trouvez ça normal
non ça me surprend et ça me fait c'est
pas normal du tout non non je trouve que
ces ententes très heureux pour moi il ya
longtemps que vous êtes la plus
populaire dans mon coeur mais là
franchement je suis content alors est ce
que vous avez commencé à vous la péter
un peu oui oui ça peut je sais pas
franchement je n'appelle pas ça qui est
bien chez michel je ne sais pas vous
allez augmenter vos prix quand même je
ne crois pas c'est pas le moment
d'augmenter ses prix en france ouais
mais non et est-ce que vous avez
continué à traîner un boulet comme
pierre palmade derrière vous avez testé
j'espère je vais le traîner toute ma vie
vous avez gardé la classe dans votre cv
j'assume tout non traité important à ce
moment là j'étais complètement débutante
j'avais adapté une pièce de théâtre et
on personnes me connaissez je voulais
faire venir les gens tat les gens sont
venus
je ne peux pas ouais donc vous gardez la
classe je garde tout ce que j'ai fait
corneau oui je garde tout alors si vous
passez chine est toujours la meilleure
quand même je suis dit que j'avais non
parce que justement quand j'étais
justement a parlé déjà à mon enfance
j'ai fait plein de trucs j'étais jamais
la meilleure parce que çà et là pour une
fois c'est bon comme attendu sans
tricher parce que je suis la preuve
voilà michel aulas qui soutient les
spectacles de jan peter on tient bien
sûr la pâte
c'est très théâtraux en tête avec mme
cukier j'en avec notre charte
j'habite à rome